Not yet.
There we go.
Now we're live.
Hey everybody.
Welcome to another webcast.
Today, joining me is Ty.
And he's going to sit down and
talk to us a little bit about backbone.
We're going to kind of go over
some of the basics of backbone and
what it allows you to do you.
For those of you who
are unfamiliar with backbone and
where it fits into the course where
it's part of the optional health tracker
web application that's immediately
after the neighborhood map.
And ultimately Backbone's just
another framework which is
going to include models,
collections, and views.
And this project is really meant
to kind of let you branch out and
explore this new framework.
Let you explore something I'm going to
Knockout and Backbone is actually pretty
common in a lot of web applications and
this actually kind of holding together
a lot of really,
really big web applications out there.
So it's a pretty desirable skill
to have worked in Backbone and
have built something with it.
So I guess Ty,
you want to introduce yourself and
explain to people what Backbone is?
>> Yeah, sure John.
So hey everybody.
Just like John, I'm a front
end coach here at Udacity and
I'm also a full stack web developer.
So, I guess the first logical thing
to start with is what is Backbone?
And It's a front end
JavaScript MVC framework.
For those of you who even don't
know what MVC is it stands for
Model View Controller.
And it's basically a design
paradigm to help you kind of
separate your front end application
into logical components.
So like the, model provides structure
for your application's data.
For example, like storing,
representing people in a database.
You could have a person,
model, something like that.
The view as the name suggests has to
do with the UI of your application and
it is the view is always updated based
on changes to the model, generally,
or reacting to user input.
So that's how the users interact with
your data and the application itself.
And the controller,
which is the C part of MVC,
you could consider kind of the brain
of the application to some degree.
It updates both the model and
the view, tying everything together.
So we'll go back to John briefly and
talk about
getting set up with Backbone for a bit
>> Yeah, and
I think, it's always good to remind
everybody to like what MVC is.
I know that should be for
those of you who have gone through
project five and everything.
Should be pretty familiar
at this point but
it's easy to kind of forget
what each component it is.
Each component is used for and you'll
probably hear it called or referred to
as a bunch of different things like-
>> Alphabet soup.
>> Right, model view, view model, model
view controller, model view presenter.
And for general purposes you can kind of
consider them all the same thing.
When you start digging deeper you
realize there's like these small little
differences, but generally what we'll
be dealing with is you know the MVC
model viewer controller.
Now as far as setting up Backbone,
it's really straightforward.
It's just,
it's just a tiny little script.
It's pretty tiny framework.
>> Yeah, if compressed I think
it's like 8 kilobytes, right.
>> Yeah super super super tiny
compared to like some of these bigger
ones you have out there like Ember,
Angular.
But obviously right that small size
means you're not going to kind of get
some of the more stronger architecture
like you get with Angular and Ember.
Or some of just the more
robust set of tools.
Backbone is just a very
stripped down MVC framework.
A lot of the decision making
is going to be left up to you.
And you're not going to
have a lot of these sort of
fancy you ways to do you things
like you have with Angular and
Ember or some of the other
big frameworks out there.
But fortunately it makes
setup pretty easy.
You just go download it
from backbonejs.org, or
you can use a package
manager like Bower.
For those of you who haven't used
Bower yet, there's a whole forum
post about it, or you can just go
to Bower.io to check that out.
And, from there,
you only need two dependencies
to run at jQuery and underscore.
jQuery are largely uses to sort
of interact with the DOM and then
underscore a uses for templating which
out of the box Backbone doesn't provide.
So it just and relies on underscore
to do a lot of the templating and
some other helper functions
included with that.
And the cool thing is along with being
able to bring these in from Bower or
download this and
include them in your project.
You can also just use a CDN
to bring them all in.
And just include them as
links in your header tag or
scripts of the bottom of your file.
That's pretty much all
there is to it to like get
Backbone included in your project.
Really, really straightforward.
It's not like something like React.
React just sounds like an entire build
process to compile your code into
usable JavaScript.
It's really straightforward.
It's written in native JavaScript, so
it should run real easily just
by importing those scripts.
So yeah that's pretty much setting up.
I think the next thing we
want to kind of cover here is
to talk a little bit about models and
collections.
And I think Ty wanted to talk to
everybody a little bit about that.
>> Yes so as with most applications,
data is a very important aspect of them.
So the way Backbone handles your data
is through what they call models and
collections, which is the same
M from MVC and collections.
You could consider like Backbones
database for holding models.
>> I think it's important to note that
the models aren't
necessarily persistent.
Like, this isn't like putting
your data into a database, right?
>> Yeah, we're not working
with like SQL or MongoDB here.
Yet you can interact with those, but
this is strictly providing structure for
your data within the code.
It's not actually saving it.
In any kind of file yet or on any kind
of remote database nothing like that.
You can certainly do that.
But this is just backbones lingo for
providing structure for your data.
So when I say model, I mean backbone
model, not like any kind of database.
So I think the concept of models and
collections are pretty straightforward.
So I actually want to jump
right into an example.
So I'm going to screen share with you
guys and zoom in a bit so you can see.
Where are we?
So you guys should be able to see that.
John how does that look on your end?
>> Hey, it looks pretty good.
Maybe just zoom in a little more.
But it looks pretty good on my side.
>> Yes, is that readable?
>> Yeah, that's readable..
>> Okay, so
we'll just step through this.
So we can ignore the first
couple of lines.
I've basically just wrapped all of
the code in an anonymous function.
After the webcast is over will
be uploading a forum post and
I'll explain why that's kind of
important in front end code, but
it's not super relevant right now.
So, we can see right here
starting on line four,
I have created a person model and
it's pretty easy.
What you do is you take the function
that backbone provides,
model backbone's a model.
And you just call
the extend function and
pass in an object with
your customizations.
So that's just a base to use
the model at the basic level.
There's really not much you have to do.
All I've done is kind of
provide some default for
let to describe some defaults
to basically describe like
what the structure of every
person is going to look like and
each person is going to have at
the minimum a name, age and gender.
And I've just kind of pick
some like sensible or
at least sensible to me defaults so
then empty strings and negative 1.
So that's it, as far as creating
the model pretty readable.
And then we're actually going to use
that person model to make me, Ty.
So, Ty-Lucas Kelley, 20 years old, male.
There we are.
And once you've actually
created that variable and
you can make much more
than one if you want.
Accessing, what it was
that accessing elements in
the model is as simple as saying,
Ty.get.
And then, in this case I got the name.
For you to run this code.
Had you imported
backbone in all of that,
it would get a little pop up that says,
Ty-Lucas Kelley.
If I wanted to change my name later.
It's just Ty.set, name.
And then, the name I want to change to.
And I'm now Homer Simpson,
unfortunately.
So at the basic level,
that's really all there is to models.
And again, we'll be providing much
more links to documentation and
more advanced tutorials,
after the webcast on the forums.
>> So where do we-
>> Will become Homer Simpson,
unfortunately, like it's a bad thing.
[LAUGH] A good thing in
the earlier Simpson's seasons,
maybe not now that we're in like
season 30 or 300, or whatever.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, that's a model.
And then there is a collection, which
you can consider a container for models.
So I made a person model and
we're going to make a collection called
people, to put persons inside of.
So, over in this file now,
which I've called collection.js.
And we have the same stuff from before
the person model nothing is changed.
And then we create on line 15,
a people collection.
And you kind of interact with it the
same way you did with the model which is
collection.extend.
And then you pass in
your customizations.
So, all we have to do at the bare
minimum is point to the model that we
want to be storing in this collection,
so that nothing else gets inside of it,
otherwise it's just
a big array essentially.
We create a collection just by
invoking the people function.
And then just like before,
I made Ty, here I am.
This time I'm not Homer Simpson.
And then, the way I added myself to that
people collection is with people.add.
So again, very readable.
Backbone is meant to be simple and
kind of stripped down.
So let's say I wanted to, I've put
a bunch of stuff in the collection and
now, I want to get something out.
I would say,
there are two ways you can do that.
I could say people.get(ty),
which is the actual model,
I just pass on the entire model.
And then, obviously,
it's pretty easy for
it to verify that it has that in there.
And then, once I get it back, I can
get my name again or change things.
I'm actually working with
the model itself at this point.
Or, if you provided like an ID number,
like a unique ID for the model,
you can get it by that.
So like, people.get, zero or
10,000, or whatever the ID is.
So either way is acceptable.
There again, there is definitely a lot
more that you can do with models and
collections including things like,
pointing them to like a remote,
Mongo DB database, something like that.
That's not what this webcast is all
about but again, after we will be
providing plenty of links and
tutorials for you guys to dive into.
And the course itself that you can
take on your desk, the dotcom.
So that's all I want to say about
models and collections for now.
And that brings us to the V.
The middle part of MVC,
and back to John.
>> Actually, I actually have a question.
>> Sure.
>> I'm not 100% sure if
you know the answer, and I don't
expect you to because I'm kind of just
throwing it to you off the cuff.
>> Yeah, go for it.
>> But, so like for a person model,
if I set these defaults.
And then I say, in your example,
his name with gender and age.
If I did something like a new person and
then I passed in a name,
a gender and an age, and then I passed
in something else like, I don't know.
GPA, let's say,
like a grade point average,
just like threw like another
argument into the new constructor.
Would that fail, would it add
that to that particular person?
So actually, backbone doesn't really.
I'm not sure if you can enforce the,
like to stick to the defaults
that I specified.
But, no.
You can totally just add in an arbitrary
amount of extra variables.
So you could create a new property
called favorite sport, and
call it football or something.
And it wouldn't complain or
give you any errors.
So the whole reason we define
the default is more just for
like code readability.
And so that, as the developer, you kind
of know what's supposed to go in there.
I'm sure it wouldn't be too
hard to figure out if you can
kind of enforce those defaults.
Actually, okay, cool, so
there's actually a model.validate
function which that you can call.
And in the case that you did provide
like extra arbitrary variables,
it would then yell at you.
But it's up to you actually to
write that validation function.
So again, kind of like we're mentioning
before, backbone leaves a lot up to you
the whole idea is performance and
small size bare bones.
But yes, so to answer your question.
Yes and no, it doesn't do it by
default but the option is there.
>> For sure.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just kind of curious what would happen.
>> Yeah,
that's a good thing to know about.
I haven't really tried that myself.
I'm usually pretty anal about like
massaging her, creating my models so
it exactly matches like
the data I'm pulling in from.
So I was just curious what would
happened if something through,
stick in the spoke on that one.
>> Yeah, definitely good for
like a larger team to be able to
actually enforce the validation though.
If you're working by yourself.
Probably not a huge issue.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Okay, so
what was I supposed to be talking about?
The view, the V area.
Yeah, so
the view is all about displaying things.
The models and
collections are about sort of creating
this data into some usable format.
But it doesn't really
present this data to a user.
So that's really what the view is for,
and what the view is all about.
So really, when you want something
to have change in your model and
be presented to the user, that's really
what the view's going to be handling.
So working with the view
involves really just two things.
One, writing a template
in your HTML files.
And that's going to provide sort of
the layout or structure for your view.
And this is largely where underscore
comes in like I mentioned before that
was one of the dependencies for
backbone.
And then the actual view code which
is the JavaScript that fills in data
from the models and
uses your template as a base.
So let's take a look at
this quick example here.
That we have right now.
Let me screen share.
I don't have fancy, or
I do have a fancy atom.
But I rather use sublime.
[LAUGH] So, I hope that looks
good on your guy's end.
>> Yeah, totally clear for me.
>> But again, you can see we
kind of have a lot of this
wrapping in on this function, which
I'm not going to worry too much about.
But just like the model, we have this
view function that basically says,
this is going to be a view objects,
it's going to be a view method.
So we just call backbone.view.extend.
And first, we pass in this L property,
which is going to be the down element
that we're going to bind into.
So in this case, we're just binding to
the body and you can see that this is
a pretty standard J query selector, just
the dollar sign and then the element.
This could also be
right any sort of div.
Or any sort of class that
we decide to pass into it.
Maybe you want to attach it to like
the main, or even IP selector.
So it supports you know anything
you can select on the DOM.
>> Yeah, just plain old jQuery.
>> Plain old jQuery,
yeah real simple there.
So then we have this initialize
argument which is basically
this function going to to be
assigned to this function.
And it's going to call
this render function.
This is basically what's called
her viewer was created and
typically you just use it to call render
function but you can also do a lot of
set up in sort of this initialized
stuff prior to calling render.
So, if you need to sort of manipulate
some things, or premanage some data,
or make some requests before
you probably render the view,
you can kind of do it in
this initialization step.
So then this one's pretty simple.
Like I mentioned,
it just calls this dot render,
which is our back dot render function.
And this is just going to basically set
up this pretty simple template here.
It's just going to make this
list item which says hey there.
this.el, as you remember from above,
is actually our body element.
So this is just a selector saying like,
pick that body element.
Append this little chunk of stuff.
And then we, down here,
actually instantiate our new list view,
which will throw it up on the new page.
So that's the basic premise of view.
There's a few other kind of tricky
things you can get away with in there,
but generally speaking this is what most
of your views are going to look like.
Stop screen sharing there.
And it looks like there aren't
too many questions on Slack,
or on the side so we'll move on
real quick to the next thing
which I believe is talking about events.
>> Yeah so back to me for that.
You know if you've been programming
with JavaScript at all you've probably
encountered events before it's just
a huge part of a Java script and
backbone to their kind of what make
the application come to life and
able to react to user input as well
as changes to like the model and
collection that you mentioned before.
If you used jQuery specifically you've
probably seen something like this.
Let me screen share real quick,
okay, so you guys can see that.
So you have seen events before most
likely so in this little comment,
right here I threw in a classic
use of j query which is
what to do when the click event
was fired after clicking a button.
In this case, it just logs
some nonsense to the console.
Or yesterday.
You've seen events before post likely.
And now, we're going to actually work
with events in the context of Backbone.
So we're taking that list view
from before in John's example.
So everything is the same so far.
Elements of the body.
We've actually added a little more.
I've created an actual HTML file here,
so ignore the errors, but
there's the body.
And we've made a button to add items and
remove them.
And then, here is our list right here.
So pretty simple.
But, I will be referencing that.
So, bam, events.
As you can see, this is backbone
syntax for dealing with events and
you basically create this events object,
which is all the events you
want the viewer to handle.
And then the key,
you have the event name which is click,
you know,
which is fired upon clicking anything.
And then the element that is being
clicked, separated by a space.
And then the actual value in the key
value pair is the name of the function.
We're going to call, and
you guessed it, we are the ones
that write that function.
So quickly scrolling past,
this is the same as before.
Except for calling it on the list.
Tag this time or id rather.
But you can see the add item and
remove item functions and
they basically are pretty simple.
When you click the add item button,
it's going to add another list item.
And when you click remove item,
it's going to remove the last item.
So nothing too crazy and, as before,
we have to actually instantiate the list
view, but that is actually the basics
of working with events in Backbone.
Just like with everything
else we've done so far,
it's pretty readable and
quick to pick up on which is very nice.
Not nearly as complex as a lot
of other JavaScript frameworks.
But yeah this object right here is
essentially mapping events to functions.
And that's all there is
to events in Backbone.
So I will stop screen sharing.
And I think we have,
unless there's questions,
I think we only have one
more thing to talk about.
>> Yeah, I think we'll take
questions at the end here.
But the last little bit
I think a lot of people
are curious about is you mentioned
before that these models you're creating
they don't really persist.
They're not like a model innocence.
And it's something that its store in
the database that you can retrieve.
Later when you create these models
they're very distraught me.
Being a sickly gets destroyed.
Once the backbone application
goes down In that instance where-
>> Where the page hits refreshed?
>> Or the, yeah,
where the page gets refreshed.
So in that instance where Ty said,
you know ty.create there was a new
person equals ti, blah blah blah.
That object is basically going to get
destroyed the next time session reloads.
So to get persistent data, and it's
something we talk a little bit about
you guys doing in
the health tracker project.
It's utilizing local storage.
And so Backbone can utilize Browser's
local storage pretty easily.
Most browsers have some
local storage support.
Chrome does, Firefox does,
I think Safari does now.
>> Yep.
And the latest versions of IE.
And the new Edge browser as well.
>> Yeah, so as long as you're not trying
to support a lot of IE 8 clients and
stuff like that, you'll probably
get away with using local storage.
And so, it's a database of sorts and
it's a really easy library to
integrate into your projects.
And so it's pretty easy to implement.
Let me screen share this
little snippet of code.
There you go.
And let me make this a little smaller so
you can see everything.
But you can see in
the collection that we create.
We specify the model that we want.
And then we just specify
local storage and
use this new backbone to local storage
and then give it some collection name.
So this could be something
like you know local store.
And that could, you know, house all
our people that we end up creating.
So now any time that we,
you know, put, you know,
information into this local source,
it's going to get saved there.
It's basically going to get cached to
that URL and then when users come back,
the data will persist at least for
a little while unless they go in and
clear their browser history and
mess with a bunch of stuff.
But generally, local storage
is a pretty simple method for
making persistent data
without having to go out and
learn a huge database
framework like Mongo or
Just zillion other ones
that are out there.
>> That's really it if you guys
are looking to learn a little bit more
you definitely should go
through your Backbone JS class
which has a lot of great
material in there,
we reference a lot of great articles and
we'll make sure to share
a lot of these useful links as well
>> But
it looks like we have some questions
that need to be answered so
how about we go through those and try
and hit on as many of them as we can.
If you guys are posting
questions in slack as well,
I'd be happy to take them there.
So let's see, Roger Woodroof
says as P five two is optional,
is it possible to complete the nano
degree minimum requirements, graduate,
and then come back and
do P five two after graduating and
still be able to submit P five two for
review.
And I actually was not 100% sure about
this before we started the webcast.
But I just talked to Rant
who's one of our CM's on
the career services side and
he says yeah, you know graduates.
You guys have access to your paths and
are able to see the optional projects
for review after graduating.
So yeah,
you guys are more than welcome to.
Finish up project five,
finish up project six.
And then graduate, come back,
do project five too and
submit that one since it's optional.
If you do have any trouble submitting
it, for whatever reason, like,
I don't know maybe you know,
if the system doesn't let you submit it,
feel free to email into us
at support@udacity.com and
we'll make sure to get
that set up right for you.
This one comes to us from Udan who asks,
I'm creating a disposable set
of views for third party data.
They have no attached models or
collections.
The user can elect to
save specific results.
What's the best approach to harvesting
the data behind that view, or
should i just create
models to begin with?
I'm leaning.
>> The models.
>> Yeah.
I'm leaning towards the making
models to begin with.
>> Yeah it's just that that's the way
the framework was meant to be used and
that's going to be the least painful and
most importantly easiest to find.
Documentation and help for
if anything goes wrong.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So if you have any kind of data that
you need to work with, definitely go
with the models and collections route,
rather than rolling your own solutions.
>> Yeah, I would agree with that too.
If you're looking for a framework that.
You know just.
You can do something like that within.
Doesn't rely on like models or
collections.
Then you're probably looking for
something like React
which just strictly VM.
>> React would be the way to go.
>> Yeah.
That that's essential.
That's actually.
Damn near the description for
a reactor is just like
sort of use that you can kind of
dispose of and set this data on.
With Backbone though I mean
it still relies heavily on well
defined models and collections.
>> Yeah, otherwise things start to
kind of look like spaghetti code and
the whole point of Backbone
kind of falls through the floor
in terms of clean
application architecture.
Yeah, I feel like you'd end up
using a lot of like jQuery,
if you just used to use no model, or
you'd end up basically writing
a model without meaning to.
I feel like that would
be the end result.
All right, let's see here.
I'm going to check the slack
channels really quick.
Bochef says he doesn't really have
a question, he was having some trouble
getting into the webcast, so, hopefully
we deliver the recording to him but
he says you starting a new job next
monday and they have some Backbone
applications there
>> Hey, awesome.
>> So yeah i mean like any any advice I
guess we can give to Bo about you know,
stepping into doing like real
heavy lifting with back bone
>> So I guess not
too much quick advice i can give
right now but definitely look out for
our forum post which is going to have
links to much more advanced tutorials
that will probably help you with ton
unlike the workplace environment.
Yeah definitely.
>> And luckily you'll be able to lean
on your coworkers shoulders too,
to learn how things work over there.
But congrats on the new job.
>> Yeah, I was just going to say that
too, is when you're stepping into, and
this goes I guess, with framework
in any job you step into, right?
There's going to be a particular way
that their engineers are doing things.
There's going to,
there'd be a particular framework
that they all like to use and
there's going to be a particular
style that they like to stick to.
So, you come in with the basics, but
definitely ask questions, inquire about.
I understand how backbone
works a little bit, but
I kind of need to understand how
you guys make backbone work.
Let's see this one comes
to us from Robert.
What are the strengths slash weaknesses
of backbone versus knocked out?
So I guess the strength of both of them
is that they're really lightweight.
You're not getting into
an overly large architecture.
I guess, versus each other.
Knockout, in my opinion,
is very much more.
Convention over configuration
where you're sitting down and
you're writing a lot of
code whereas a backbone
I think is a little bit more structured
to not know and so you kind of have
a little bit more of this configuration
set up where you're basically defining.
More or
less you're defining these objects and
their properties,
whereas with Knockout you're kind
of writing the code building
those objects and properties.
>> Yeah, and
if I can chime in real quick.
So both these frameworks, they're
similar in the sense they both kind of
fill that kind of smaller second tier
niche in terms of JavaScript Frameworks.
They're not quite as big and
all encompassing as something
like Angular or Ember.
You know and as a result they're
a lot simpler and lightweight.
The one big difference between
the two frameworks is,
in something that's called
two way data binding.
So this is something that Knockout
has and Backbone does not.
So in Knockout it's
a little bit simpler.
To have Your views and models.
Kind of stay up to date with each other.
Whereas Backbone, you have to do
a little more of the wiring yourself.
It's certainly not impossible to do
the same things with both frameworks,
but that is one small
advantage of Knockout.
It's a little simpler to keep
things up to date with each other.
Without any like dom manipulation or
kind of manual I'm not sure what
the word I'm looking for is.
Yeah but that's about the only
difference between the two,
they both kind of fill
the same void in terms of like
a small lightweight
JavaScript framework.
Yeah.
I tend to lean a little bit more towards
Knockout, largely because of the two way
data binding, and
the ease of setup with that.
It's not terribly
difficult with Backbone.
It just is a little bit more work.
>> Luckily because Backbone's
been around for a little while,
well both frameworks have there
are there's a lot of like.
Good third party code out there and
OpenSource code you can find.
To kind of take care of some
of the heavy lifting for you.
But yeah that's about it on that.
>> All right.
Let's see if we can help this guy out.
Prada asks, I'm trying to
build a backbone application
which interacts with
files on Google Drive.
Where should i place
the Google API calls?
In the model or the controller?
>> The controller would be the place for
that.
Any interaction with third party APIs or
outside resources should go there.
The model should purely be for
defining the structure of your data.
You want to keep that as kind of.
Pure quote unquote as possible.
So definitely go for
the controller if you're working
with the Google Drive API.
>> Yeah.
I agree with that.
That's basically right from
the definition of what
the controller is, right?
It's all the code that interacts with
the model and interacts with the view.
And in this case you know that API call
fits perfectly into that sort of piece.
The robber
asks do you have a screenshot of
a sample interface for this project.
So a sample of the health tracker.
I mean, do you have a copy on
your on your laptop right now?
>> I might.
Here, let me see if I can whip something
up real quick, give me a second.
>> Yeah, yeah, no problem.
I don't know,
I'll double check my laptop
too, but I recently did
a full reset the other day.
Here we go.
I can share something.
So there's a bit of set up with
the project that I have on right now so
thank you why isn't adequate
work correctly without
throwing a bunch of errors this alike.
I need to put in there but
as far as the basic what the u.i.
could look like if you wanted
to implement it yourself.
The screen Perfect.
So that's about that.
So you can see,
there's a little search bar at
the top the title of the application.
Search results are going
to go on this left third.
And then, this is the actual Health
tracker that keeps track of how many
calories you've had.
So that's pretty basic,
not too fancy with the CSS.
But that's kind of a good structure for
this type of application.
Search bar at the top,
search results at the left and
then the actual report taking
up most of the screen.
So there's a little sneak
peek at what we came up with.
Yeah and just since there is,
we can't really shelf date our activity.
>> We got to leave some work for
you guys.
>> You're basically right.
You just type into that search bar and
then a whole list of categories,
or sorry.
>> A list of results of
foods would come up.
The user would be able to pick one and
basically add it to their, what they
ate that day or week or whatever.
>> Yeah, and there's much more details
of course in the actual backbone course
we have on our website and
the project rubric.
>> Yeah, we definitely encourage
you to make it not so plain.
We're just [CROSSTALK].
>> And you do a better job
than I did with the CSS.
[LAUGH] You put me to shame.
We're just lazy and
need to get things working.
So we use a lot of Bootstrap.
>> I will never complain.
I will never claim to be a designer.
I respect those that
can make that claim.
>> I know.
I was I was perusing job listings
just seen what people were asking for
for like junior and senior front end
web developers, and there is a large
misunderstanding of what a front end
developer and front end designer are.
There's so many that are like, okay we
need you to know HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
And two different paths.
>> No.
>> If you can learn it all,
then you should have no problem
getting a job anywhere.
>> Yeah.
>> Props to you if you've got
development and artistic ability.
>> I was thinking that some of
the more intense development stuff.
All right I think we've got time for
one more question here and it's kind of
a fun one which is from Etine and
he asks what brand of coffee do you buy.
>> Boy toughest question.
Okay I'm a big coffee and tea drinker.
I don't really buy any one particular
brand but I am picky with buying
whole bean coffee needs to be ground
right before I'm about to drink it.
The coffee I'm hooked on lately,
you can actually get it,
Ii you've got a Trader Joe's near you.
It's this new Mexican Fair Trade
blend they have.
It's very, very nice.
It's got a nutty flavor.
As far as like if I'm out and
about and grabbing a cup of coffee.
Not too much preference.
Starbucks over Dunkin Donuts I guess.
Not to start a flame war.
>> [LAUGH]
I guess i'm kind of on the same
boat as you, not too particular.
As long as it's not crappy and
as long as it's
>> Good coffee.
That's the easy answer.
[LAUGH]
>> Fresh.
I guess my drink of choice if I
had to pick one is like Americano,
just straight espresso in
the cup with some water.
>> Caffeine IV.
>> Yeah, pretty much.
I don't think we've got
any other questions here,
I'm just going to take
a quick glance at slack.
It looks like we're okay.
For those of you who are watching or
recording and
were able to get and,
I am sorry about that.
We're going to do our best to you this
on something that doesn't require
being a part of the Google Plus
community beforehand.
I think the next one who are going to do
is going to be posted on YouTube Live,
so there won't be any sort of
like gate and we want to try and
like you accept people as
they're trying to join in
any way as any last thoughts
on anything today insights?
>> No I hope you guys we're able to
get a nice intro to Backbone and
get your feet wet again,
definitely keep an eye out for
the forum post that's going to be
coming right after this It'll have
basically everything we cover today
as well as some important links to
code examples and tutorials,
things like that.
>> Yeah, and along with that,
we'll be taking questions there.
So,feel free to post any other
questions that you might have.
Let us know you know where
you're struggling with Backbone,
where you're struggling
with the project.
We're always happy to to dive in and
give you guys some support.
All right, cool.
Thanks, Ty!
>> See you everybody!
Thanks for popping in.
>> Bye everybody.
Have a good rest of your evening.